aftermath of an Inferno this house was
completely incinerated by the huge
wildfire that ripped through Mariposa
County in California's Sierra Nevada
mountains the heat was so intense it
melted aluminum parts in cars turning
them into shiny dribbles of metal
the fire broke out on Friday and quickly
exploded in size engulfing thousands of
hectares and forcing thousands of people
to evacuate dozens of structures have
been destroyed
firefighters say years of drought
extreme heat and millions of dead trees
killed by invasive bark beetles turned
to small Blaze into a monster we're in a
dramatically major drought so what you
see is you know immensely dry conditions
not to mention the beetle bark period
that killed a lot of these trees that
are now dead standing along with low
humidity major or hot conditions that
just made a recipe for disaster and then
yeah so when the fire swept through here
it literally blew everything up about 3
000 firefighters have scrambled from all
across the state to this remote
mountainous region
they douse hot spots cut up downed trees
and build fire breaks
when there's no roads the fighting is
done from the air a steady stream of
helicopters drop water and fire
retardant on burning hillsides the work
has begun to pay off we've made really
good progress and that's because uh you
know the conditions the weather
conditions have been on our side the
amount of resources that we brought here
have also helped and also the you know
the wind has died down so that has
allowed us to to keep the fire from
spreading
the cause of the fire is under
investigation California and other
Western States have been dealing with
severe wildfires year after year each
one worse than before
the early start to California's Fire
season over the past several weeks sends
an ominous signal soon blustery Santa
Ana winds will blow through these bone
dry forests making fires more likely to
break out and harder to fight Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Mariposa County
California